there Jane thank you now as we know
those hundreds of thousands of fans
awaited hours in the sun she was just
talking about to get a good spot along
that Parade Route 8 news now reporter
Joshua peguero caught up with a few who
shared how important the golden knights
are to Las Vegas
most of the golden knights here is gone
but even that high 90s couldn't keep
fans away earlier on Saturday a
lightweight shirt sunscreen hats and
lots of drinks it's going to be hot out
here but we wouldn't miss a parade for
anything
it was shoulder to shoulder near the
Bellagio Fountains the parade route
began on Flamingo as double decker buses
pulled up full of players and staff
getting the party started we needed
something like this here in Las Vegas
like I said I've been here for a long
time and
um needed a team to come here and have
something to go to and lift our Spirits
Stanley Cup champions some fans still
remember what it was like during the
golden knights's first season in the
wake of the October 1st Massacre when
they went to the Stanley Cup Final and
lost it gives the city something to
Rally around after the shooting had
happened so I think it was excellent I
think it was a great thing it took us
six year six years and they brought a
couple
of homes are riding the high off of this
year's Stanley Cup win against the
Florida Panthers a lopsided victory that
secured Vegas's Championship status me
and my husband my husband's a truck
driver and we couldn't watch the game
together but we facetimed the entire
time so it really means a lot to us the
fans I spoke to say they're already
looking forward to a repeat of a Stanley
Cup Championship win putting on the
Strip Joshua piguero eight news now